um so blessing do you want to put the
next clip Up
oh can I just add something yeah go
ahead
um I just thought it would be
interesting to mention this Men actually
do better after a divorce and women do
significantly worse so it's just like oh
they you know they're
they were great and then they'd actually
get greater after a divorce and women
actually plummet their finances
everything goes
yeah and I think also when I actually
realized like that you know they can
actually keep that money invest it make
that grow and they you know it's because
it's not going into a black hole
unfortunately
so that's something to think about
what about the women who
essentially get 50
from their uh husband or take everything
from them does that still equate to them
the man still like after gets up off his
feet and does he still do well and the
woman still does bad or is it yeah yeah
because he he can manage his money
better and it's not you know um let's
just say you've had like a surplus or
anything he can reinvest that as because
it goes back it links to women being the
biggest consumers she's got her divorce
she's gonna sorry I keep doing that
thing boy she's gonna get her hair done
and her nails
I got divorced I'm gonna go spend all my
money
there's divorce parties now oh yeah
which is so like sad like and they go
out they go all out and I'm like that's
all you're alimony
the irony
well here's the question when do you
think it's appropriate to start
splitting the bill on dates I am more
than happy to go dutch I believe in
equality for all so I I like the yin and
the Yang of a guy pan sometimes I'll pay
sometimes it kind of sets the tone for a
relationship and you know I got your
back you got my back having said that if
it is the first date
he better offer to pay or there will not
be a second date
well I will say I love it as a gesture I
think it's really sweet and I appreciate
it but a lot of times I feel like no I
want to go dutch on the first date
because we're both feeling each other
out and I don't want someone to assume
something so I I like to know well
I mean
I feel like it just depends on the
delivery right yes like if the check
comes and he looks over at me like yeah
yeah then so you need to you need to go
ahead and put down on this and I'm gonna
go
um not never to be seen again but I
think I think that needs to be discussed
early on right like how how much of a
date is this are we still are you
interested in courting me for real or
did you did you ask me out or did I ask
you out or was this like a setup by
friends I feel like those things need to
be discussed early on communication will
eliminate any room for error in that
situation yes
have we done this poor of a job with our
young men yeah have we have we not
talked our younger men but this is
really supposed to be about
I'm sorry the way it is supposed to work
and I can appreciate everything you all
are saying because you women so quite
naturally you set the tone for how you
are
but let me say this to men
it's the it's the proper thing to do
it's the right thing to do and it's the
way it should be done
you got a lot of nerve you know dudes
kill me because we got a lot of nerve
thinking this thing is 50 50. because I
got news for you it ain't they happen to
have a skill set that you'll never
possess they can produce another human
life
you nothing you can do can come close to
that I'm ashamed of men who don't
understand them in addition to that part
of the conversation it needs to be made
clear to men that women don't owe you
when you take us to dinner just because
you buy me dinner just because you paid
the valet doesn't mean I need to go home
with you absolutely so that in that same
conversation that still needs to be said
and I think that's why so many women
still want to pay because you don't want
to be bought because you don't want the
perception of the obligation exactly
because now I am not for sale correct
yeah because nowadays A lot of times in
this situation the women might be making
more money then he need to play in the
playground he qualified to play
[Applause]
[Music]
were born to be a provider you were born
to put a woman on a pedestal and treat
her like a queen that's your job as a
man now if you don't want the job go do
something else it's an honor to take a
woman out hey
this pissed me off right here
[Applause]
look at all these men I've been looking
at this man right here with the lady
next and lady in the teal is that your
husband
this dude been getting he been going
yeah the whole time that dude up there
with the lady with the with the sad show
he even yeah cause he that man with the
blue t-shirt on with the lady with the
green t-shirt I've been looking at all
these men going yeah cause we know just
how this work y'all getting tricked man
these young dudes out here man if you
don't understand that and don't email
the show tomorrow see you got money
Steve ain't always had money I had
nothing I have never ever in my life
from every date I've ever went on and
Adam been on some dates
had a woman pay for nothing for me
different time different times this was
when I was good in post if I'd had the
money I saved it so I could take out
yeah yeah I'm sorry man all right we
gotta take a break we got more straight
talk when we come oh my God can there be
two king of simps I think Derek's been
dethroned oh my God
why tell me why that was too much man
first of all how old is he I don't know
40s no no oh my God
he's on the way it's a different
freaking time it's like
how can you say that oh yeah you know I
didn't have a job before I was broke oh
yeah every single day I paid it was
probably it was much more less than it
is now there's just so many things to
consider and he's not even yeah that was
yeah that was again offensive yeah and
like they didn't I mean as Michael was
saying earlier like I don't think the
women then were sleeping with the other
guy yeah that was like true courtship
yeah beating to a serious relationship
marriage commitment all that good stuff
yeah all of the guys and couples that he
pointed to you in the audience looked
old
I don't see anyone that looks like six
they looked like they look weak you know
their wives brought them to that oh
absolutely and he knows he has to clap
for everything bro
you're using old people as a measuring
stick for the current Society it doesn't
correlate so it doesn't it doesn't work
bro and like again he's saying oh don't
email because you're saying I've got
money but you do have money though we
talking about bro in the UK the the
energy prices have gone up considerably
house prices have gone up considerably
it's not easy bro
do you know what I'm saying like I
really can't stand these people that act
like everybody's balling we're not all
living some uh rock star life it's
unrealistic bars yeah and like at the
end of the day he's talking about oh
yeah this is your honor what do you mean
bro the woman is a stranger bro
and and with that all that advice yeah
oh yeah you need to pay on the first
date make sure the date is cheap bro
every guy watching this year let me tell
you keep the check the date cheap then
it ain't gonna it ain't gonna hurt you
bro maximum 50 pound maximum Max I agree
because if I like a guy I don't give a
where he takes me if you if you
really like it like if you're really
into a guy you don't give a he can
take you to freaking make that if you
really like him like you might you might
you know wish it wasn't McDonald's but
you're still just happy to be there yeah
you're happy to be there yeah inside
you're gonna be like oh I wish you took
me to a little restaurant but you're not
gonna care bro I'm telling you on one
hand the amount of girls that I've taken
out on a date like a proper date like
one hand bro and those girls were
already my girlfriend bruv
so I've already found out or or like the
realization has come that she actually
likes me and she's invested in one way
maybe not monetary but she's invested
she's invested time energy there's no
one word answer replies like she's
actually showing enthusiasm to get to
know me and that and show me that she
likes me bro that's somebody yeah okay
boom I can take you out but not for some
stranger bro and all of that is a lie
bro and they're trying to turn the
majority of men into Sims they're trying
to feminize uh men mention that have a
backbone we shouldn't have an idea or a
perspective on anything this is whatever
the woman wants it goes bro you got
stupid idiots like Steve Harvey 99 of
his audience are women all clapping old
old women clapping yeah like what are
you talking about bro it's propaganda
it's nonsense bro you know what I'm
saying so at the end of the day he's
just the same he's just trying to make
money I understand get your bag but bro
anybody with half a brain will
understand that this is this is BS bro
do you think women owe men sex if he's
taking her out of multiple nice dates
I wouldn't say oh that's that's a strong
word oh that's like deserve see what I'm
saying no one deserves anything and I
don't think a woman owes a man sex but
at the same time bro like everything is
in exchange in this world bro like if
you're if you're if you're dating a guy
you know the guy wants to sleep with you
I don't care how nice he is to you I
don't care how he how he talks to you
you know he wants to sleep with you bro
so if you're dating a guy and you know
you don't want to sleep with him you
shouldn't be dating him RAV
that's it
I mean other people might not agree with
that but why why would you be seeing a
guy that you have no intention of
sleeping with them eventually so what
you're just gonna be dating him dating
him dating him he's going to be wasting
my time and money for what for a girl
that's not interested this is what I'm
saying this is why I can count on one
hand the amount of girls that have
actually gone out there and spent proper
money on a date for those girls were
already my girl
and guys need to understand because
guess what that girl that you're
spending 200 300 pounds on on a
restaurant at hakasan or Gaucho yeah
that girl is sleeping with a guy for
free
yeah I'm saying so it's all right I'm
not trying to hear any of that bro
serious and I've been that guy to sleep
with girls for free many times bro you
know what I'm saying Jim dates bear gym
dates come on man
gym dates yeah gym dates get me what is
it a gym day okay boom let's say yeah
yeah workout together okay okay let's
work out together or um what's it even
even simple let's go to the the uh
shopping center just walk around they
worked out with you and they wanted to
hook up after sweating
yelling at them and stuff no I'm not
actually training them I'm not training
them they're like we're going there
together like you know what I'm saying
yeah I'm gonna go there anyway
it's real like that and again it's just
like what you said if the girl if the
girl likes you it doesn't matter where
you go bro yeah I agree so true that's
so true take me to Popeyes and talk to
me that's all I want I want chicken
sandwich and everything more time
exactly more time you eat one sandwich
have one drink the drink will you you
drink half the drink you'll be there for
like two hours just talking because you
actually like the guy you're interested
in the guy when these girls talk about a
guy who has to pay this and he has to
take me here that's for the guys they
don't really like they use it that's
what it is yeah I don't I don't think
it's always like
conscious you know like but I do think
like a lot of times like women were so
indecisive that it's like like I don't
know sometimes guys get taken advantage
of you know
you're saying guys get taken advantage
of because what women are indecisive
um
personally I don't have a ton of free
time so like I wouldn't I think my
time's valuable so if I don't like a guy
I'm not gonna go on a date with him but
I think a lot of guys like wait for
years in the friend zone and I think as
women like we kind of know this
and sometimes like it
but he's in the friend zone for a reason
because you know you don't like him so
he's not indecisive you just don't like
him he's just there yeah that's true
he's doing it to himself really yeah
that's true as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible